well they're invisible in Washington
uncounted by the official unemployment
numbers you hear on television and yet
they're everywhere Americans who have
dropped out of the workforce workers who
don't work and ever-increasing
percentage of these are male about seven
million American men between the ages of
25 and 54 no longer have jobs that's
more than 10% of the entire prime age
male labor force in the United States
it's a huge number most of those men
studies predict will never return to
work what happened well some of the
causes are well known competition from
foreign manufacturers crushed our
country's industrial sector China's
entry into the WTO alone destroyed more
than 2 million American jobs Automation
is killing many more a disproportionate
number of these jobs are in traditional
email industries manufacturing
agriculture logging a 2016 McKinsey
report found that quote 90% of what
welders cutters solder errs and brazzers
do could be replaced by robots and soon
jobs in which women are the majority
tend to be far less vulnerable to
automation three of the five fastest
growing professions are dominated by
women the jobs that remain for men tend
to pay less that the ones that
disappeared this is especially true for
working-class men who unlike their
female counterparts have seen seen their
real wages fall over time a part of the
reason for that is mass immigration more
than a million new immigrants enter this
country every year legally a large but
unknown number come illegally most of
these are low-skilled all of them are
looking for work these new rivals
compete primarily with the very
Americans most likely to have lost their
jobs and the effect is lower wages it's
a matter of supply and demand an
overabundance of anything makes it
cheaper and that goes for labor one
study conducted after the Mariel
boatlift in Florida found that Americans
with lower education levels in Miami the
most vulnerable saw their wages fall by
37 percent after the immigrants arrived
policymakers didn't seem to notice and
they still don't probably because it
doesn't affect them if waves of
immigrants from the third world are
becoming lawyers and nonprofit
executives
members of Congress how long would the
borders stay open meanwhile millions of
American men now make less than their
fathers did that's a tragedy it's a
betrayal of the American dream but it's
also a recipe for societal collapse when
men's wages decline families fall apart
this fact is well known to researchers
it's been the subject of many studies
over decades with consistent results and
yet it's rarely noted in public here's
some of what we know when well-regarded
study released last year found that when
men's wages fell relative to women's
families didn't form according to the
authors of falling male wage reduced
quote the attractiveness of men as
potential spouses thus reducing
fertility and especially marriage rates
researchers also noted a dramatic
increase in out of wedlock births when
men made less in the words of one of the
authors an economics professor at MIT
quote we see a decline in fertility a
decline in marriage but a rise in the
fraction of births that are
disadvantaged as a consequence that kids
are living in pretty tough circumstances
numerous academic studies have reached
the very same conclusion research from
2015 found that quote when a randomly
chosen woman becomes more likely to earn
more than a randomly chosen man marriage
rates decline those who do marry report
being less satisfied and are more likely
to divorce low male wages are a driving
force in family dissolution and that's
why affluent neighborhoods in which men
make more have a higher proportion of
married couples and fewer divorces the
opposite is also true and that leads to
a cascade of social problems which over
time become a disaster men who make
lower wages marry less and furthermore
children out of wedlock these children
growing up without fathers tend to make
lower wages themselves in later life for
decades this was a universally
recognized pattern in inner cities the
cycle of poverty much was written about
it now the same destructive vortex is
common in rural America the cause is in
culture that's what we thought no in
both cases the cause is the same a lack
of well-paying jobs for men
what's striking is how little notice
these facts get from our policymakers
their overriding aim is to raise women's
wages to parity or above men's there's
nothing inherently wrong with that but
these are complex questions with
numerous and profound unintended
consequences so they deserve a vigorous
public debate it's notable that most
women the very population on whose
behalf these policies are supposedly
devised strongly prefer to marry men who
make more than they do but what's beyond
debate is that Washington and corporate
America aren't thinking a lot about how
to solve the male wage crisis if
anything they're exacerbating it
lawmakers in both parties for example
have heartily embraced self-driving
vehicles and drone delivery of packages
it's all impressive technology but what
would be the effect on employment has
anyone asked that there are more than 3
million professional truck drivers in
this country it is the most common job
in the majority of American States more
than 90 percent of drivers are men
thanks to technology many of these men
are about to lose their jobs it's a lot
of unemployed Americans that's a lot of
broken families Washington is not
worried at all about this lawmakers and
business leaders assure us that those
truck drivers will be just fine they'll
find something else to do something
better in fact with higher pay and maybe
they will but keep in mind our leaders
said the very same thing about
manufacturing jobs 30 years ago